davy de la mobilisation est elle au
rendez vous et bien déjà quelques
centaines de personnes ici réunis place
denfert rochereau pour contester à cette
dissolution du groupe génération
identitaire je me trouve justement avec
les deux porte parole de générations
d'auditeurs clément martin et à icd ce
qu'ils font merci d'être avec nous sur
arte france
alors pourquoi c'est important pour vous
ce rassemblement encore une fois cet
après-midi parce que nous voulions
rappeler l'importance de la liberté
d'expression et la liberté d'association
dans ce pays qui sont actuellement
gravement mises à mal par le
gouvernement et par gérald darmanin en
particulier qui souhaite 10 ou deux
générations identitaire pour des raisons
bassement politiques d'une part mais
aussi à travers nous finalement il ya
une volonté de criminaliser le discours
anti immigration dans ce pays or on peut
encore être hostile à l'immigration en
france sans que ce ne soit ni
condamnable ni au motif de dissolution
gérald a maintenant vous avez les dix
jours justement pour répondre à cette
lettre qui vous a envoyé quels sont les
arguments que vous allez lui donner tout
simplement que juridiquement parlant à
gérald darmanin n'a pas les outils pour
dissoudre génération identitaire cette
lettre de qui a annoncé notre
dissolution elle s'appuie sur des chefs
d'accusation qui était la constitution
2010 d'une part et l'incitation à la
haine
sachant qu'en fait pour l'opération que
nous avions menée dans les alpes en 2018
où nous avions déployé une bande une
frontière symbolique entre la france et
l'italie
nous avions eu un procès pour
effectivement constitution de milices et
nous avons été relaxé par la justice en
décembre dernier
donc la justice elle a déjà tranché pour
pour ce chef d'accusation là et en ce
qui concerne la situation à l'ail nous
n'avons jamais été condamnée non plus
pour ce chef d'accusation nous n'avons
jamais eu de procédure judiciaire et
tous les propos que nous avons jamais pu
tenir ont toujours respecté le cadre de
la loi et la liberté d'expression une
forte mobilisation qui rapporte qui est
attendue cet après midi un important
dispositif de sécurité qui étaient
miennes a également remplacé qu'est ce
que ça vous inspire ce dispositif de
sécurité à nous ça fait plusieurs jours
qu'on est en lien avec la préfecture
justement pour ce rassemblement puisse
se dérouler dans les meilleures
conditions et donc notre rassemblement
était autorisée et comme vous pouvez le
constater il ya un déploiement de forces
de police assez conséquent pour
permettre de sécuriser cette
manifestation et qui se passe au mieux
et que cet événement comme tous les
événements que génération identitaire a
pu organiser se déroule pacifiquement et
au mieux pour vous cette action de
gérald darmanin les anti démocratique
oui complètement c'est à dire que
comme a pu le dire effectivement clément
martin il va criminaliser le discours
anti immigration alors que fâcheux dire
général gérald darmanin peut dissoudre
génération identitaire est ce qu'il va
dissoudre pour autant 63% des français
qui selon un dernier sondage de l'ifop
sont inquiets des migrations massives
nos actions elles ont toujours respecté
le cadre de la loi nous sommes des
lanceurs dalet d'alert pardon nos
actions elles sont toujours pacifiques
et symbolique
même lorsque nous étions allés dans les
pyrénées dernièrement le préfet de haute
garonne avait reconnu que nous n'avions
causé aucun trouble à l'ordre public
donc encore une fois on voit bien que
ces motifs ce sont des motifs politiques
et ou de idéologique parce que ils
essaient de faire du en même temps l
emmanuel macron c'est à dire que d'un
côté voilà il va dissoudre baraka city
et le ccf qui sont des organisations
pour le coup islamistes avec de réels
liens avec le terrorisme et va nous
mettre sur le même plan d'égalité que
des personnes qui veulent le détruire
l'identité de la france et donner des
gages à la gauche
en dissolvant génération identitaire
merci beaucoup d'avoir répondu à nos
questions voilà vous l'aurez compris en
tout cas la mobilisation s'annonce
importante ici et place denfert
rochereau et un important dispositif de
ce qu'il a été et été mise en place pour
qu'il y ait aucun débordement lors de ce
rassemblement de génération il était
tard afin de protester contre la
dissolution de ce gros merci david
khalifa en direct donc de la place
denfert rochereau à paris resté avec
nous on revient vous voir évidemment
pour continuer à prendre le pouls de
cette manifestation